en este vídeo tenemos el siguiente
problema se dice que se midió la presión
sanguínea de siete pacientes luego de
consumir cierto medicamento durante tres
meses su presión sanguínea aumentó en 15
29 09 39 32 21 y 19 puntos en cada uno
de los siete pacientes en los que se
realizó esta este análisis después nos
pide construir un intervalo de confianza
del 95% para el aumento de presión de
todos los pacientes de la población
entonces tenemos
las siete muestras de nuestros siete
pacientes una para cada uno y queremos
averiguar un intervalo de confianza del
95%
antes que nada entonces realicemos
nuestro pequeño esquema
la distribución normal esto es una
distribución normal ya que es un proceso
biológico el tema de la presión
sanguínea
vamos a tener
un determinado valor de sigma y esta va
a ser la distribución normal de toda la
población del aumento de la presión o de
la presión mejor dicho de toda la
población
pero bien para nuestra muestra de siete
pacientes vamos a tener un x barra
que va a ser la media aritmética de esas
muestras de 2,34
también por los cálculos que ya
conocemos podemos averiguar el desvío
típico de un 1,04 pero qué sucede en
este punto
en este es el punto en cuestión de este
vídeo
nosotros podríamos decir que él es vídeo
típico podría ser 104 podríamos estimar
lo sin embargo estaríamos cometiendo un
error
esto podría ser aproximado verdad
estaríamos cometiendo un error en este
caso en este problema en particular
tenemos una muestra de sólo 7 pacientes
sin embargo en el universo de los
pacientes son mucho más de siete
entonces en este caso ese no es un buen
estimador porque es muy chica la muestra
normalmente un buen estimador sería a
partir de una muestra de 30 pacientes en
es cuando de 30 experimentos por así
decirlo en este caso como sólo tenemos 7
pacientes nuestra es el valor que
calculamos de ese no es un buen
estimador entonces vamos a analizar otra
cuestión de la estadística que nos va a
permitir solucionarlo
vamos a utilizar una distribución
distribución
t
una llamada distribución te vamos a
bajar acá
comentarles que la distribución t es la
más adecuada para estos casos en los que
tenemos una muestra pequeña la
diferencia de una distribución t radica
gráficamente en que tenemos por así
decirlo colas mucho más gruesas
vamos a tener
también
su x barra que es de las medias
muestrales la distribución muestral de
las medias muestrales que va a ser esta
distribución t y vamos a tener el valor
del desvío típico
en este caso el desvío típico va a estar
dado por los valores que nos dé la tabla
de valores de la distribución t
entonces como nosotros queremos
averiguar el valor para un 95% de
confianza y tenemos una muestra de 7
esto muestra de 7
37 y 95% de confianza
en la tabla de valores z lo que vamos a
hallar es estas colas el área que hay en
estas colas
o mejor dicho no del área que hay en
esas colas sino el área que hay acá pero
pero con los valores
que van a faltarle al 95 por ciento es
decir ahora cuando veamos la tabla van a
comprender qué es lo que le digo estas
colas que están acá es lo que les falta
a este 95 por ciento es decir es este de
subir entre estas dos colas
formamos un 5% de la falta
sin embargo vamos antes que nada vamos a
dejar esto para después vamos a estimar
de todas formas lo que sería nuestro
sigma sub x barra según como nosotros
estuvimos trabajando en vídeos
anteriores esto va a ser igual al sigma
sobre la raíz de n que en este caso es 7
también podemos decir que en vez de usar
el sigma podemos usar el mejor
estimativo que tenemos el mejor
estimador que es ese
y en este caso vamos a obtener como
resultado ese es
y el resultado de esto
nuestra sigma sub x barra va a ser igual
0,39
0,39 este valor nos va a servir aunque
no va a ser el exacto para poder
utilizar este valor vamos a tener que si
buscar una tabla de valores z
nosotros sabemos entonces vamos vamos a
la tabla
vamos a la tabla para comprender mejor
todo esto de lo que hablamos acá tenemos
la tabla td student de dos colas
estudiantes él
estudiantes es ese es el seudónimo del
matemático que descubrió que inventó
esta tabla y tal voz set
set
vamos a agradecerle a él cada vez que
usemos esta tabla entonces nosotros
tenemos que buscar el área del 95% es
decir tenemos el
095 sin embargo lo que vamos a buscar en
esta tabla es lo que yo les decía es
esas son las colas es decir el 0.05 lo
ubicamos por acá 0.05
como tenemos ahorrar vamos a hacerlo con
rojo como tenemos una muestra de 7
valores no vamos a buscar en la fila 7
sino que vamos a buscar en la fila n
menos uno es decir siete menos uno
6 este 6 va a ser 6 grados de libertad
se le llama grados de libertad entonces
donde se encuentre
el 6
con el 0 05 es decir en dos coma
447 es el valor que nosotros estamos
necesitando
otra cosa que me quedó pendiente voy a
volver a la tabla esta es una tabla de
dos colas de student fíjense que acá
está aclarado que es una tabla de dos
colas también se encuentra la tabla de
una cola que es cuando en él
en la distribución
no solamente necesitamos las dos colas
valga la redundancia sino que
necesitamos sólo una
pero esa es otra tabla distinta a esta
que también se puede encontrar en
cualquier página de internet o en
cualquier libro de estadística ahora sí
volvamos cuando nuestro
tenemos acá nuestra distribución para
estos valores entonces averiguamos que
el valor que necesitamos es 2 447
que es justamente el área voy a borrar
acá
si se me permite
y eso
ese valor 2 447 es el área de una de las
colas
d
nuestro gráfico
es decir acá este área
y kaká
es 24 47 24 47 a lo que hay que
multiplicarlo en unidades
el desvío típico y vamos a introducir
una simbología que es este este pico
sobre el sigma que va a ser cuando
trabajemos con la distribución de tablas
es decir que el valor es de que hallamos
nosotros también le vamos a
y aplicar este simbología
entonces
si queremos ahora averiguar entonces
dónde se encuentra el verdadero mundo
tendríamos que hacer que está esto 2 447
por 0,39 y esto nos da 0 96 horas y 0 96
es el valor del área este sí es el valor
exacto del área
por lo tanto
por lo tanto podemos afirmar
o podemos asegurar
en un 95% vamos a poner aseguramos
aseguramos
mejor dicho aseguramos
que hay
un 95 por ciento de probabilidades
y la probabilidad de que
x barra y recordemos que era x barra x
barrera 234
x barra igual a 234
este /
del verdadero
esta es otra forma de decir que el
verdadero va a estar en 234 con un
margen de error de 0,96 verdad entonces
podemos decir justamente eso
podemos decir que tenemos un 95 por
ciento de certeza
de probabilidad
de que um
de que la media de la población de estos
pacientes a los que les puede subir la
presión sanguínea esté entre
/
0,96 del valor 234 que es x barra que es
la media muestral entonces quiero que
quede claro más que nada el uso de la de
la tabla de valores p
o mejor dicho de la distribución de la
tabla salvo que se desprende de eso
distribución
que es cuando tenemos una muestra muy
pequeña un valor muy pequeño menor que
30 por así decirlo entonces de ahí
pudimos deducir que el 95 por ciento de
probabilidad de que no se encuentre de
la media muestral que era
234 con un margen de error de 0 96